the Antarctic continent is the coldest
driest windiest place on earth
pristine white and sparkling blue it
holds more than 60% of the fresh water
on the planet yet it's fierce frozen
interior is inhospitable for most forms
of life
it's a different story in the
surrounding sea where the Atlantic
Pacific and Indian Oceans meet to form
the Antarctic or Southern Ocean
their distinctive array of life
flourishes and waters that name just
above freezing krill translate the sun's
energy gathered by green phytoplankton
into protein that yields food to support
the entire Antarctic ecosystem
blue wins spin Wales minky right and say
whales migrate thousands of kilometers
each year to feast on krill it's also a
big part of the diet of fish seals
penguins sea birds and many other forms
of life
the Antarctic southern elephant seal is
the largest seal in the world and its
cousin the leopard seal does a
reputation of being the most ferocious
six species of Finland's breed in the
Antarctic the Adelie which is the most
common and the emperor which can grow to
more than a meter high as well as the
chinstrap gentleman came and macarena a
little awkward looking waddling sliding
on icy surfaces underwater penguins are
streamlined his bullets and seen the new
owners as fast
more than 40 species of flying birds fly
the orders of the other pig hooting
patrol and the school at school large
fierce Providence greeting penguin s6
and eggs we steal the catch of adult
birds sometimes killing risky
recent expeditions in the Antarctic
swittel sea produced some scientific
surprises more than 700 new species
giant sea spiders huge icicles
enormous coniferous sponges and huge
starfish
new methods for exploring the cold dark
waters around Antarctica are providing
insight into the nature of this
previously unknown part of a planet
today more than 30 permanent year-round
scientific stations got the interview
scientists are tracking the global
warming patterns in the region and the
shifting ocean currents monitor the
shrinking ice mass and the impact of
climate change on Antarctic life of and
below the ocean surface protected by its
remoteness daunting climate most of the
southern ocean remains a mystery unknown
and unexplored
you